[Music]
so we're gonna go to stephen in
greenville south carolina united states
of america what's up steven
how you doing today i'm good my brother
how are you
good uh i know you're probably excited
about this that poetic win by
uh oliveira over poirier on the weekend
was not very uh poetic man
but hey i gotta i will i'll call it what
it is guy's good man guys real good
and uh
play is real good too man it's that's
tough to get foyer to roll over and
man hats off to aloe vera who are you
rooting for
uh i was uh i was rooting for oliver you
would you would stephen that's all right
what's up dude
uh so i'm calling in uh trying to figure
out how to mend a relationship my dad's
in a
relationship with somebody that's i
don't know if you'd say half his age
more than half his age or less than half
his age
and how how old is that person
in relation to you
are you all the same age
no they're
seven years older than me my dad's 71
they're 30.
you're 23
yes sir
is that weird
it is um especially of course there's a
she has a five-year-old daughter in the
situation as well okay
so
yeah man you and i could hang out and
have a beer and talk about this for a
long time so
what's your question
uh what's the best way to mend that
because additionally to that he said
that he has the family that he's always
wanted
oh man that's
way to go dad
um so when you say men tell me more
about that
so uh
well
i'm on a speaking term with him okay
i'll go see him for his birthday we'll
meet up for lunch
on my birthday
but uh i guess another additional part
of this question would be that my sister
hasn't really spoken to him in two years
because uh
that was a big fallout with them so just
the whole
family ordeal i'm the only one that goes
over for christmas and like i said
birthdays and stuff yeah and we'll talk
on the phone occasionally but it doesn't
extend past that have you done something
that violated your dad's trust in you
um i haven't have you done something
that
um
would violate the values
that a son
like the respect and dignity a son gives
to his dad
no sir because when all this started we
actually had a business where we were
working together and then that was the
fallout of that as well
so the heartbreaking thing here brother
is this your dad chose a new family
and there's nothing you can mend here
because you didn't break it
right
and for whatever reason
your old man has decided
to cut ties from
his original
family and to create a new one and
whether it's in his head or whether he's
trying to relive something
by
hooking up with somebody 40 years
younger than him
like whatever it happens to be
um
unfortunately man it's not your not only
is it not your job you can't
paint me a picture of what you wish it
would look like
i mean just more of uh
more inclusive where we can actually go
down go out with him have a dinner or
something but he told you he wants
the other family
right
why don't you have dinner with him is he
like a jerk when you all are out
together does he say no all the time is
he like some kind of racist bigot idiot
like wha
what are the things that keep you all
from getting together
well
um ever since they've gotten into a
relationship he's become
i guess you'd say vulgar like he chooses
to cuss a lot i get
mad at things that
aren't a big deal like uh on my birthday
we were just sitting there eating
because where we happened to go was
closed on the inside so we sat
in the vehicle and ate and he saw
somebody walking up didn't like the way
they liked got upset about i'm kind of
mad about that and it's just he's
changed so it's not a
not the
enjoyable guy he used to be
what changed in him like what happened
i don't know ever since this
relationship it's uh it's like he's
always on edge and
his favorite line he likes to go to is
because i mean a lot of people don't
talk to him as much as they used to his
favorite line he likes to say is that
nobody ever asks him if he's happy but
he's happy now and he just keeps saying
that over and over and over almost like
he's trying to convince himself
exactly yes sir oh man
so here's what you got to do
um and you've heard me say this a
thousand times you're gonna have to
process this and grieve this
any relationship with your dad
there's a picture in your head of what
you would love to see and it's not gonna
happen unless your dad gets struck by
lightning and has this moment where he's
like what am i doing
and um
unfortunately you see this happen all
the time all the time all the time did
you have a lot of money by the way
uh
not that i'm aware of
[Laughter]
well
maybe this 30 year old your your this 30
year old new wife of his looked up and
just like i i love seven year men and um
this is my ride maybe that maybe that's
it um
bam but you're gonna have to have this
picture you're gonna have to grieve it
you have to say this isn't what my life
is beared out and this isn't what it
we drew it up is what we wanted this is
what we deserve man we deserve a dad
that loves us and wants to talk to us
and wants to be with her they're kids
um you didn't get that man and i'm
heartbroken for you
and then the next thing to do is to live
in a picture that's reality
and
this is all you can control is what's
going forward and my you know i
recommend this all the time i'd
recommend you write him a letter you
probably aren't going to send it
get that stuff out
and then sit with your sister and say
what what are we working through and
then i'd find a couple of other men who
are older than you in age and connect
with those dudes
and maybe it's the first season maybe
they break up in a year or two and he
comes back to you and says what in the
world is i doing and then you get to
walk down the road of forgiveness and
reconnection all that but he's going to
do the reconnecting
you're just his son
and you've treated him with dignity with
respect and you continue to and he's
chosen a different path and he's
i can't imagine looking at my two little
kids and saying
finally i get the family i wanted i
can't even wrap my head around that even
sound honest
that sounds like a hurting old man who's
trying to make sense of his place
sorry brother
wish i had better news for you man
you're a good man keep being a good man
keep treating people dignity and respect
we'll see you soon